the Joe Rogan experience imagine the
pterodactyl days what in the [ __ ] was
that like yeah giant flying lizard chats
fellow carnivores yeah [ __ ] that you
imagine there it is
whoa what that sounds like quetzel quota
which is the that's that that Aztec god
qu etz ALC oh atl us
Quetzalcoatlus Quetzalcoatl was that
that flying God of the Aztecs key just
go back up to that I was reading that
top part right there yeah
a pterodactyl Petrus or from the Late
Cretaceous of North America largest
known flying animal to have ever lived
so that is like probably they probably
named it after crustal quatl which was
the see if you find that word
Quetzalcoatl because I think that's what
that was it was an Aztec god that was
like a bird wingspan of 36 feet jesus
Kirti six feet Jesus Christ what the
[ __ ] that's a plane now see this is a
god the feathered serpent a name for the
feathered serpent deity of the ancient
Mesopotamian Mesoamerican culture I
wonder if there was ever a time were
human beings and that Petrus or thing
coincided when was that Petrus or when
did that thing go extinct that
Quetzalcoatl us you imagine if there was
a Newman you know Neanderthals or
whatever Australia Pittacus and you're
looking up you see a 35-foot bird [ __ ]
you man
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you we're discovered in
Texas that's the same course right area
of course Texans before the Comanches
they had giant flying dinosaurs John
dance fast for a time period
doesn't say right off the top for some
reason just whatever would Late
Cretaceous so I don't know what's that
when does that at ten million years what
is that think it says a hundred to 6600
so that's way before even the Yucatan
impact that killed the dinosaurs that
was 65 million years ago the climate was
warmer than now even then what's the
biggest thing that lived that flu while
people were alive I think was that HA
steagle you said that was three meters
right that's nine feet by the way [ __ ]
that to imagine a nine foot I don't take
your kid easily I don't take endur'd
small kid may be a pretty big kid yeah
they carry deer away oh [ __ ] how do they
pull goats off the side of cliffs and
not even big ones dad have you ever see
that Golden Eagles do that Golden Eagles
are the biggest North American Eagles
and I've actually think bald eagles have
done this as well
and they swooped down and they grabbed
these sheep that are trying to climb
their way up to the top of these
mountains they pull them off and they
they drop them on the rocks yeah and
watch them smash Wow
and sometimes they ride them down to the
ground Wow dude there's one video this
one eagle he grabs ahold of this sheep
and pulls him off of the sheep or goat I
forget which one was pulls it off the
side of this wall and as it's going down
the Eagles hanging on so the eagle hits
the ground with it and bounces it and oh
my god it's [ __ ] madness it's madness
that's beautiful
they meet Eagles fine fine eagle fell
bounced had this goat hit it in the head
bounced fine
the end flies away yeah crazy flexible
bones that they have [ __ ] yeah dude
we're so lucky we have one thing to
worry about right now other than normal
[ __ ] that everybody has to worry about
all the time in life one new thing and
everything just hits to a halt when one
new thing
and our world changes what new thing
right
albatross has a bigger wingspan than the
hostel really it's about to say maybe it
says it's 11 feet Jesus I won't but rust
the ones that are alive right now
Wow that's what are they mostly fish
right and this even says a condor with a
24 foot wingspan that's 28 million years
ago so Oh sorry Nica albatross they go
out to sea for [ __ ] weeks what do
they do just dive in and eat fish I
haven't eat yeah look at that whoa yeah
that would be just more annoying than
anything I don't think that could kill
you but an Eagles got a face like a
bolt-cutter there's a couple as I was
digging through a couple articles even
speculated if those uh giant what's the
Codel things some others like Petra so
if they were too big to even fly maybe
mmm they could have been like giant
ostrich type bird oh right or type
things yeah they only have the bones
right big wings yeah just something that
just got too big for its wings didn't
need to maybe get fly like a chicken
like chickens can fly like you know
they'd fly like ten feet or something
like that they just kind of run fly at
the same time to get a little get a
little air no I think about like my
friend had a a parrot when I was a kid
parrot or a parakeet I don't know Birds
but it scared the [ __ ] out of me like I
would reach into the cage just to like
you know you try to stick your finger in
its belly so it steps on your finger but
it bites you instead and I remember
being a full-sized human being scared of
this take that and expand it by a
thousand yeah and it's flying above you
yeah birds can scare the [ __ ] out of you
yeah they can pull a [ __ ] salmon out
of a flowing river with their feet and
fly away with it yeah imagine even
grabbing a salmon imagine just dunking
your hand into a river and pulling a
salmon out no I'm now imagine doing them
while you're flying in you snatch it
pull it out of the river and then fly
away with it all right
and that's our American
that's our national bird national animal
it's pretty cool national animal I guess
it's a ruthless [ __ ] of a flying
dinosaur yeah
would it be better if we had something
compassionate be that close oh they're
real close shoe bills are super
dangerous
oh yeah well that is an ancient
predatory carnivorous dinosaur that's
that happens to still be alive why is
that guy getting close to it with his
kid oh don't do that please don't do
that yeah I could imagine if that thing
was pissed off at you well we can touch
it bro that's the kind of people to get
eaten I think we're fine oh I think
we're fine
I'm gonna bend over and pull up my pants
there are some animals that are dangers
a really aggressive bird casts away I
think it's called and this lady's
filming on the beach in Australia she's
like oh look look at the cool bird and
the bird starts going after her they'll
come [ __ ] with you what is it a ballon
Epps's rex Shoebill stork facts that's
what it's called Bala Nexus Rex
it's a Rex it's a [ __ ] dinosaur look
at that face Wow look at the mountain
that one right there look at that one
look at that image what in the [ __ ] is
that that's that's flightless right yeah
but it gets to five feet tall and it
snatches fish and lizards and all kinds
of things swallows them whole there's a
fantastic documentary that bbbc put out
years ago about the Congo and the shoe
bill lives in the Congo and in the in
the Congo the shoe bill eats this
there's a fish that comes out of the
land and then crawls across the land
till it could find another pond and then
slides into that pond yeah and the shoe
bill is eating that thing and you're
like what am i seeing I'm seeing a
battle between two prehistoric animals
well that's a maze of fish that can swim
and then climb out of the water and walk
on the ground and then jump in a new a
new pond right that's the that's the
missing link for evolution the first
animal that for
fish to get out of the water
[Applause]